[Music]
foreign
time
uh
hello I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it's September 12
2023 why we just cold opened you there
with Dylan Mulvaney and his new job as a
folk singer I have no idea but once
again I saw it thus I thought you should
see it I don't know why guys were live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and locals
share subscribe tap that notification
Bell if you have not as always post game
show at reubenreport.locals.com if you
have any comments questions you want to
correct me on anything share your
thoughts
etc etc and today
we will talk about that machine that I'm
always focused on because it's always
one step ahead of us somehow it always
fools us it enables the worst people it
destroys the good people we expose it
yet it still exists and right now one of
the big things the machine is doing it
is going after Elon Musk hardcore uh
because of his stance on Ukraine now
it's not just his stance on Ukraine and
what he's done with starlink and we'll
get into some of that in a second but of
course it's more broadly because of his
stance on free speech he basically is
for free speech he has turned Twitter
into more of a free speech platform than
it was before when it was a hyper
controlled platform a hypersensorious
platform a platform that was quite
literally working with the government to
silence you he has uh pulled back on
that just a bit and they're very upset
about that so the machine and I'm
talking corporate media I'm talking our
politicians and the rest of it they are
trying to destroy him uh we will connect
that to also what's happening with our
immigration policy right now which is if
you say anything remotely sane or honest
about immigration say oh I don't know
maybe we should have a border we should
have a border I have a door at my house
and not everyone's just allowed to have
the keys and just wander in I don't just
leave the door open and say oh
everybody's welcome to come into the
kitchen and eat whatever you want if you
say basic truths like that they try to
destroy you and also if you note that
the president or the man pretending to
be the president of the United States
Joe Biden is old and unpopular they also
will lie about you and of course if you
are an orange man you will lie about a
Florida man that's how it works people
that's what we're covering today and
before we get to it let's talk about
bambi.com guys when running a business
your employees can create all kinds of
interesting situations like getting
complaints because someone on the team
smells horrible Phoenix Phoenix well you
better talk to Bambi with Bambi get
access to your own dedicated HR manager
starting at just 99 per month they're
available by phone email and real-time
chat so onboarding and terminations run
smoothly team members reach Peak
Performance and your business stays
compliant without with changing HR
regulations and with Bambi's HR
autopilot you'll automate important
practices like setting policies training
and feedback Bambi's HR managers are
dedicated they're us-based person who
will cater to your business by giving
you access to the HR expertise and
personal touch you need HR managers can
easily cost 80 grand a year but Bambi
starts at 99 per month schedule your
free conversation today to see how much
Bambi can take off your plate just go
right now to bambi.com type in Ruben
under podcast when you sign up it'll
really help the show
b-a-m-b-e-e.com bambi.com type in Ruben
under podcast and now back to me all
right
have you guys heard of this war not war
that's happening over there in Ukraine
uh we're funding this thing uh we're
given weapons we're training doing all
sorts of stuff but of course we have not
authorized a war we don't actually say
the word War uh it's just an endless
Money Pit you I think you've heard about
you guys have heard about it yeah we've
all heard about this thing uh well one
of the things that has happened in the
midst of all of this uh is that starlink
which is basically Elon musk's satellite
internet service has been used at times
by the American Military by the
Ukrainian military and Elon Musk has
realized that perhaps he doesn't want
his technology being used to further a
war that he is concerned might take us
to world war three that is I would say a
legitimate concern well uh Jake Tapper
Democrat activist Jake Tapper over on
CNN head Secretary of State Anthony
blinken on his show over the weekend and
they were talking about how Elon Musk is
not letting the U.S government do
whatever it wants whenever it wants
whether Elon should be punished
SpaceX CEO Elon Musk has recently
confirmed a report that's in Walter
isaacson's new biography of mosque that
last year musk blocked access to his
Starling satellite Network in Crimea in
order to disrupt the major Ukrainian
attack on the Russian Navy there in
other words musk effectively sabotaged a
military operation by Ukraine a U.S Ally
against Russia an aggressor country that
invaded a U.S Ally should there be
repercussions for that
Jake I can't speak to a specific episode
here's what I can tell you
starlink has been a vital tool for the
ukrainians to be able to communicate
with each other and particularly for the
military to communicate in their effort
to defend all of Ukraine's territory it
remains so and I would expect it to to
continue to be critical to their efforts
so what we would uh hope and expect is
that that technology will remain fully
available to the ukrainians it is vital
to what they're doing
I don't know that you can't speak to it
you won't speak to it are you concerned
that musk is apparently conducting his
own diplomatic Outreach to the Russian
government really none of this concerns
you
Jake I can't speak to conversations that
may or may not have happened I don't
know
um I'm focused on the fact that the
technology itself starlink has been
really important to the ukrainians it
remains so sounds like starling's so
important the US government doesn't want
to risk offending a capricious
billionaire who did some things that I
think in another situation the US
government might want to say something
about but let's move all right there's
two things that I really want to point
out on this regardless of how any of us
feel about the war whether Elon Musk
should help or shouldn't help what is
what are your rights as a private
citizen even though if you have
government contracts or you get
subsidies Etc to have the government or
in this case the army use your
technology let's put some of that stuff
aside for something the two points
really first off Jake says that uh that
Elon Musk had diplomatic Outreach to the
Russian government as far as we can find
there is no evidence of that that Elon
Musk reached out to the Russians
regarding any of this he pulled back
Starlings disability from the U.S
government in this case because he
didn't want to instigate he didn't want
to help instigate a military attack that
could blow up the whole damn thing but
as far as we could tell there is
literally no evidence of that if any of
you are watching and you can prove me
wrong on that or correct us or clarify
that please do let me know the other
line though that I think is the scary
line really gets to the heart of it Jake
Tapper says should there be
repercussions now again it doesn't
matter what you think whether Elon Musk
should allow this technology to be used
or not but the idea that a journalist is
asking the Secretary of State basically
should we take out should we imprison
should we find this private citizen
because he's not helping you ramp up the
war the non-declared war effort just
because you want to he has different
feelings about it and he didn't want to
as I said instigate World War III uh
this seems like a bit of a problem right
like is Jake Tapper a agent of the
machine or is he a journalist well I
think you know your answer on that one
but it continues because it's not just
CNN and Jake Tapper that is pushing us
more and more to war it's also MSNBC The
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC and Rachel Maddow who I thought
she retired can anyone didn't didn't she
quit or they got rid of her or something
does anybody am I making that up
completely didn't no she's still there
she's still everyone's looking at me
likely she's still all right I guess
she's still got a show I thought she
quit or something anyway uh she's really
into this Ukraine war lefties used to be
against the war now they're really into
war it depends who's in charge of the
time and she went on to talk about Elon
and trying to scare the hell out of him
just like Jake
Mr mask making sure that the Ukrainian
military could not use his starlink
satellite internet Network which is what
Ukraine uses for connectivity on the
battlefield
um to advance that operation
so I mean not to
simple here but
like Mr musk is American he's an
American citizen and it is the explicit
out loud not at all hidden totally overt
totally emphatic policy of the United
States government
to support Ukraine in its war against
Russia after Russia invaded them
there's this one American private
citizen who is intervening to try to
stop Ukraine from winning the war to try
to stop from Ukraine from defending
itself against this God it's so much
nonsense first off Phoenix is checking
if she still has a show a Daily Show
it's unclear to me she's at a weekly
show maybe whatever okay let's put that
aside for a second
um just try to reverse this for a second
imagine if it was Donald Trump who was
the president right now and this whole
Ukraine thing was happening and we're
marching to work now first off every day
on MSNBC they'd be screaming that he's
Hitler World War III is coming blah blah
blah then in the same exact case and
it's not just Donald Trump if it was any
if it was freaking Mitt Romney John
McCain the ghost of Ronald Reagan it
wouldn't matter they'd be telling you
that this is the worst war possible
there's going to be genocide all of this
stuff but imagine it's one of those guys
and then Elon Musk the tech billionaire
does the exact same thing he doesn't
give the mean Republican access to
starlink so that they can't Advance the
war she would be on television saying
the complete opposite she would be
saying this guy's a hero he did whatever
American Patriot should do which is
stand up to the government and stand up
to those mean people and all that I am
being told that Rachel Maddow only has a
show on Monday nights might I recommend
any of you find something better to do
on Monday nights Monday Night Football
Wings sit at home alone in the basement
with the lights off whatever anyway to
continue just a fur uh just a bit
further with this story uh Walter
Isaacson who is the guy that authored
the new Elon Musk book the biography
that this whole story is based on he
actually clarified a bit about this
issue after seeing the kerfuffle uh on
television about it he wrote to clarify
on the starlink issue the ukrainian's
thought coverage was enabled all the way
to Crimea but it was not they asked must
to enable it for their drone sub attack
on the Russian Fleet musk did not enable
it because he thought probably correctly
that would cause a major war
so the point of this guys is that he
didn't pull back anything actually
Ukraine wanted him to change the rules
that they had all been playing by anyway
all of this happens and Elon Musk as he
consistently has done decided to defend
himself publicly and I thought this was
quite good he said I am a citizen of the
United States and have only that
passport no matter what happens I will
fight for and die in America the United
States Congress has not declared war on
Russia if anyone is treasonous it is
those who call me such please tell them
that very clearly I mean that is a clear
and cogent response once again you might
you might be watching this I happen to
fall more on the isolationist side of
this not completely isolationist I say
it all the time I've written about it in
both my books I believe that you should
have a strong military as a as a
deterrence right speak softly and carry
a big stick but you might be on the more
side you might be more of like let's say
a Nikki Haley person or or a Mike Pence
person where you really want to arm them
and you want to stop Russia in that way
to me that just escalates the war you
might be more on the isolation side it's
not really all about the specifics of
who's right about that what it what it
really is about right now is not only
again that we have not declared war
we're not even debating it anywhere
anywhere we're just giving them endless
money remember what was it about six
months ago we had Rand Paul on Rand Paul
tried to bring a bill to the Senate
where all he said was hey can we just
get some receipts uh we're given
billions of dollars away is anyone I I'd
like to write this off could anyone
check in on this and then of course they
couldn't even get that we are just
handing them cash and more cash and as
we played Mitch McConnell the other day
we've just got to give them 500 million
more and a billion more
just absolutely bananas so it's it's
about not only that we haven't declared
war but really how the media I mean
these are these are supposed impartial
journalists who are banging the drums
beating the drums to drive us to war and
if anyone goes oh maybe we don't want
World War III there should be
repercussions right Jake Tapper and Mata
who would have just said the complete
opposite just ridiculous but what
happens guys when the reality of
mainstream media politics set in how how
do they backtrack when things happen
well one thing that we see happening all
the time is if you're a good guy and
you're a good Democrat you're a nice
liberal you let everybody in nobody's
illegal we love everybody but then what
happens uh people start showing up and
crime goes up women are getting raped
cities aren't safe a bunch of problems
start happening this this is a Friday
clip we didn't get to play it yesterday
because of covering 911. this is a
Friday clip out of you and and I guess I
say this a lot but like this is top 10
view Insanity so the New York City is
being overrun by illegals right now
we've shown you the clip of Mayor Eric
Adams basic basically being like you
better get the F out of here I can it's
nothing I can do man you're screwed it's
coming everywhere Upper East Side
downtown below Houston doesn't matter
you're F sorry anyway the ladies of the
view and the view is shot in New York
City they're finally realizing that if
you let thousands hundreds of thousands
of people into your city it causes
problems but now
because a liberal a conservative is just
a liberal mug by reality now look at
their response now that it is quite
literally at their doorstep this is well
spectacular
but frankly you know I think we need to
find and we've dealt with this before I
I lived in uh in Miami I was a migrant
an immigrant in Miami in the 80s you'll
remember when we had the Marielle Boat
Lift 125
000 Cubans yeah came in a matter of six
months it puts tremendous stress on on
on a city on a community on the social
services they need to be resettled
elsewhere
this is a massive country and it's only
going to get worse with global warming
and climate change because people can't
live in certain parts of this world
I can't even write fast enough to do
this segment properly first off they
need to be resettled elsewhere do you
guys know the phrase NIMBY not in my
backyard it's the hypocrisy of these
Elite rich women they don't give a
when this is happening in the Border
towns of Texas how many times on The
View have they ever covered a Border
Town in Texas being overrun by illegal
immigrants zero the only time they've
ever covered any of this is when they
show up in Martha's Vineyard right when
DeSantis sends them up to Martha's
Vineyard 20 people where they could have
been on Obama's uh 30-acre estate each
taken an acre they would have been okay
you could even put 30 people on an acre
on one acre and they would have been
okay and then they care about this stuff
so this idea first off they have to be
resettled also there's like a twang of
like Nazism in there we'll resettle
these dirty people they can't all be
here spread them out throughout the
country how about you can't come into
the country in the first place but it's
just it's so incredible it really is
just so profound really astounding how
easily you can punch holes in their
hypocrisy and and in the nonsense that
they espouse all the time because the
second it hits them then they care then
they're into resettling and spreading
people out again okay you want to spread
people out how about outside of the
United States that might be okay and
then finally joyless Behar with her yes
it's climate change guys it's just going
to keep happening because of climate
change but we can't have everybody
coming to the Upper West Side because I
want to go to zabars and I can't have
homeless people sitting outside just
absolutely insane speaking of insanity
the man who is in large part the problem
here is Eric Adams the mayor and again
Eric Adams and you can go back to our
videos during the last New York City
mayoral election everybody was saying oh
Eric Adams he's the same Democrat he's
not a complete leftist lunatic like Bill
de Blasio or some of the other people
running he's not a mate you know just
like an absolute socialist
whack-a-doodle and I kept saying oh you
just wait uh so he opened it Sanctuary
City it's been a sanctuary City will be
a sanctuary City nobody's illegal well
here he is now that uh they're having
some problems because Critics on the
right have noted that New York City is a
sanctuary City and this migrant crisis
comes with that territory what do you
say to those who think uh you relinquish
your right to complain about the
stresses it places on your city because
of that well I I think that those
comments coming from those far-right
trump-like Republicans who are continue
to try to distort the reality that we do
not have real immigration reform that we
should allow a true decompression
strategy or protect our borders in the
right way and make sure that when you
look at this city the status of right to
shelter of no one who created this
decades ago took into account that we
were talking about hundreds of thousands
of people potentially coming to coming
to the city guys nobody who thought of
this stuff thought people might actually
show up how was I supposed to know if we
said we're a sanctuary City come here we
won't kick you out we'll give you all
the services and everything else we we
have a zillion of examples a zillion
examples of this across Europe that are
countries like Germany that have
problems now because they let in
millions of people and now their social
services are collapsing how would we
know if you said to people show up we'll
give you Dental Care we'll put you in an
apartment and all that stuff that people
might take us seriously
whose fault is it really of course it's
the mean Trump Mega Republicans and the
people not taking care of the Border
except I think
um is it a Democrat or a Republican
president right now Democrat President
right it's his guy it's the elderly guy
right so everything he said there is
complete nonsense he deserves this I
pity the four the four or five remaining
sane people who's still staying in New
York City off the top of my head Gutfeld
loved that Greg Gutfeld he's still there
who else is I guess Dana Perino I don't
know if she no I think she lives in
she's outside of the city who else is in
New York City still oh Rudy Giuliani
lives there no Megan Kelly fled
so basically we got Rudy Giuliani and
Greg Gutfeld if and and my mother-in-law
so if any of you want to win I'm working
on getting her down here if any of you
want to come to Florida but beyond that
I just don't want any of you people here
anyway it continues secretary uh
Department of Homeland Security uh
majorcus right Alejandro mayorcas this
guy Mr eyebrows over here uh he he can't
figure out what's going on here there's
so many problems and if only someone had
his job that could fix these problems
first and foremost we're dealing with a
broken immigration system a fact about
which everyone agrees it is one of the
rare things about which there's
unanimity of views and we need Congress
to act number one number two within that
broken immigration system we are
challenged by an unprecedented level of
displacement in the western hemisphere
of historic proportions we have
responded with a model approach that has
proven to work which is to build lawful
Pathways for individuals to arrive in a
safe and orderly way what model approach
is working do you know who has your job
it's you what are you talking about this
largest Western immigration like
everything they say it's I admire it I
truly admire it at some level the level
of stupidity the level of the complete
inability for them to ever look in the
mirror you gotta admire it in some way
the ignorance is bliss part of their
resistance
it's just extraordinary but okay they
lie about everything and part of what
they've been lying about at least
related to the immigration part of this
is that there's a democrat in charge
right it has significantly gotten worse
from Trump to Biden fact Trump was
trying to build a wall and they said a
wall is racist most of these people live
behind walls and Gates and have armed
security which they don't want for
anyone else but we went from that to
basically letting everybody in and and
the chickens are coming home to roost so
what does the machine do when more and
more people start realizing oh the
cities are collapsing crime is
everywhere the economy is not working
crime is through the roof because of all
these illegals all of the social
services are struggling
we're going back to the view ladies and
gentlemen and fake conservative Alyssa
Farah now she's supposed to be the
conservative who would defend a
conservative point of view
maybe defend a republican every now and
again she's always going after DeSantis
but here she is doing a little PR she
used to be in PR here she is doing a
little PR for the Democrats one thing I
wanted to say on the vice president's
response and maybe this is just my PR
mind the first words out of my mouth
would have been Joe Biden's going to
serve four more years but I'm ready that
was the only thing that I kind of took
it as don't even acknowledge from the
Democrats perspective that there is a
chance she might have to step in because
it re kind of gives fuel to this
narrative that allegedly 73 of Americans
feel that he's too old the bigger
picture here 20 24 is giving me 2016
Vibes all over again whether it's the
massive Republican field that's actually
just making the way for Donald Trump to
be the nominee but then also I get he's
an incumbent but the sort of Coronation
of Joe Biden reminds me of Hillary
Clinton primaries are meant to create
the best general election candidate I
actually think if he was kind of being
challenged in a primary he'd he'd come
up with the best way to answer about
Hunter Biden the Afghanistan withdrawal
you've passed all these bills but why do
people not feel like the economy is
better and I worry that we are careening
into the matchup that nobody wants again
Donald Trump versus Joe Biden and that
there's a very legitimate chance that he
could lose okay I will give credit where
credit is due I think at the end she's
basically saying that Biden should have
a primary right because he should have
to defend some of his ideas I think
that's what she sort of said there I was
writing down a whole bunch of things
during that uh but the idea that she
made sense is so bizarre and whatever
okay so that's one part I'll give her
credit for but this other part we should
just uh ignore we should just ignore
that 73 of Americans feel he's too old
uh no we should not ignore that that it
doesn't matter if you're a Republican or
a Democrat that is a huge issue that he
is and again it's not purely about the
age if you if you were hyper
energetic and Hyper competent at 81
years old then I suppose you could be
the the president of the United States
still but again does anyone think this
guy for one day could be assistant
manager at McDonald's and the answer
obviously is no the handlers the people
who tell them what to do the note cards
the rambling the confusion we'll show
you some stuff from Vietnam and India in
just a moment uh it just it never ends
with this guy but but on the Alyssa
Farah part I don't like making about
these people specifically but she's
brought on this show called The View
which which again we've talked about
this a lot I think we've shown you the
beginning the original beginning of the
view that Barbara Walter set up from 20
plus years ago the whole purpose of the
view was to take women of different
life's Lifestyles different backgrounds
ethnicities religions color of skin all
those things and together they could
discuss their viewpoints and thus would
be the view right that was the original
idea but what you get is you get five
sort of crazy far lefties and then one
fake conservative I would say she's
someone like Alyssa you're basically
just controlled opposition you're there
to basically destroy Republicans and
conservatives and and take out your own
side and and do it nicely enough so you
get pet on the head and you get your
cookie and then one day they'll take you
out too so again as I've said it's like
lady I hope you're enjoying what does
she get paid per year have we ever
Googled that it's a couple hundred grand
right I hope it's worth the 400 Grand
like that's a nice salary and I hope I
hope it's worth it to like sell out
everything that you purportedly believe
in anywho uh yesterday was September 11
2023 the 22nd anniversary of the worst
terrorist attack in American history
obviously Alyssa power makes 200 Grand
that's it that's the level that she's
selling out for okay uh anyway it was
the anniversary of uh 9 11. and you know
I kind of struggled on social media
yesterday because I really just wanted
to do a couple heartfelt things like I
did on the show yesterday and then you
start seeing the lying and how
everyone's politicizing it and then
everyone you we just all struggle with
this I think to some extent if you're on
social media like you want to be your
best self you want to honor the day the
people that pass and all that and then
you just see the people lying and then
you you just get involved in a different
way and I got caught up in it a little
bit too but here is the elderly man
pretending to be President Joe Biden now
he did not go to New York City on the
anniversary of 9 11 yesterday he was in
Alaska and here he is completely making
something up
to renew our sacred vow never forget
never forget
we never forget
each of us each of those precious lives
stolen too soon when evil attacked
Ground Zero New York
and I remember standing there the next
day and looking at the building I felt
like I was looking through the gates of
hell it looked so devastating because
the way you could away from where you
could stand oh I knew you know it's
funny before we even show you what the
lie was I knew as I was watching it I
was like I was in New York City
on 911 as you guys know I just knew
there was just no way in hell that the
senator from Delaware showed up on
September 12th I just knew it uh well of
course here's an image where was Joe
Biden the next day yeah he was in DC at
the Capitol look it's not like it's the
biggest most egregious lie the guy has a
has lied about much more but why do
these people lie about everything I
would say in most of the politicians
cases it's it's because they're sort of
trained to lie that's in many ways
that's their whole objective it's the
whole thing is to confuse you from what
the truth is in the Biden case it's like
I genuinely think he doesn't know what's
going on so here he was this is like two
days ago in India and he just doesn't he
just does not know what he's saying
and I particularly want to thank Prime
Minister Modi in the Crown Prince of
Saudi Arabia Muhammad bin solemn so
excuse me Muhammad Salam and the
president of underline and the European
commissions and census uh he's not
speaking today uh I wanted to or maybe
you're speaking today
I had a note he wasn't speaking at any
rate I'm going to stop there
yeah you're right Alyssa Faris 73 of
Americans that think something's wrong
with them they should just be ignored
right put your PR hat on how do we get
rid of people who are seeing reality as
clearly as it's being laid out to us
anyway it continued because on this trip
Not only was Biden in India he was in
Vietnam he went to John McCain's
Memorial in Hanoi and he stepped on it
foreign
[Music]
Joe you don't step on the flowers
okay okay you get it there's just an
endless amount of these things
but guys here's here's the key part of
this because I know you're watching
you're going Dave I know you can dump on
the Dems all day long and I know you can
crap on the fools of the view and make
fun of Biden and all that stuff but
there's a there's another problem as
well and you're right there is another
problem because it's not just the media
and the Dems who are lying their way uh
about virtually everything it's the
entire machine and the Machine is not
just left wing right the machine is both
left and right it's Democrat and
Republican one side may be worse at
times and sometimes it flips but one of
the real problems that most of you
watching this I think will have to
address at some point is for those of us
that that probably are going to vote
Republican in the next election uh the
the Trump thing the endless line coming
out of the Trump thing is is a problem
you know I thought this would be an
interesting way to frame it I was
thinking about it this morning you know
when Trump came in in 2015 for the 16
election one of the things that we
started realizing was that politics is
Downstream from call culture right this
is an idea that Andrew Breitbart had
been talking about for a long time like
you could have all of the right
political ideas but if you're losing the
culture you're losing Hollywood you're
losing what the music is and the things
that people think are cool you'll never
be able to win the political thing
you'll never get enough people to back
up and and to back you up and come out
fighting for you and all of those things
and Trump came in and he started
Shifting the culture and that was
extremely important right it really it
really absolutely was uh which is why I
did not have Trump derangement syndrome
even when I was not supporting him and
it's why I supported him the second time
around but the culture right now our
culture right now is so filled with lies
in every which direction that I think
Trump is starting to do something very
dangerous with his new level of lying
which is always about DeSantis which
tells you it's like if you're up 50
points why are you always lying about
this one guy could it be possible that
you actually know that the polls the
national polls don't mean anything and
everything else but Trump is just lying
over and over and it does not give me
any great pleasure to do the segment
we're about to do because I would prefer
that not be the case but I know that
many of you are still supporting him and
I'm not telling you not to I'm just
telling you to think about what he is
potentially doing to the culture even if
he wins okay
so so let's check out this video uh this
is from Team Trump so this is the
official team Trump account on Twitter
putting out an anti-desantis ad about
covid and you'll and then Community
notes hate it you'll see take a look
like anything
you've ever seen backing up traffic for
miles yesterday
age delays there some people waiting
hours to get to that checkpoint give no
say what are checkpoints in Alabama but
as you can see here in Florida Governor
Rhonda Sanchez issued an executive order
I am recommending to the Board of
Governors who are going to talk to the
university presidents about going to
remote learning for the rest of the
spring semester at all Florida
universities restaurants uh we're going
to do similar to what California did
bars and nightclubs uh effective 5 p.m
today you know they're going to be
suspended for 30 days I worked with
Miami Beach mayor in Fort Lauderdale
supported their closures of some of
their beaches more restrictions put in
place tonight in Miami Beach the
Entertainment District between 5th and
15th streets is getting an 8 PM curfew
we're going to suspend for two weeks any
vacation new vacation rentals in the
State of Florida the governor issuing
executive order 2087 ordering vacation
rental property is to suspend operations
I talked with one business owner that
said he's tired of hearing about
closures he wants some good news Daytona
Beach Shores Police say last night their
officers went around to all restaurants
and bars handing them a copy of the
governor's executive order they say
they're out tonight patrolling to make
sure everyone's in compliance okay so
that was from the official Trump account
on Twitter now first off Community notes
which as you guys know this is the
fact-checking apparatus of Twitter now
well they hit it with a couple points
they wrote misleading DeSantis consented
to restrictions later than 30 other
states based on Trump's Federal guidance
to Governors and at the request of his
administration DeSantis began reopening
in phases April 29th based on cases and
population lockdowns ended in September
so what's interesting about this is
Trump's putting out an ad going after
DeSantis for the exact things that
Trump's Administration was asking
DeSantis to do DeSantis not only
implemented them later but rescinded
them earlier and we all know this and by
the way it is not to say that DeSantis
was perfect on this Perfection on this
would have been never complying with
anything ever and virtually nobody did
that well certainly nobody from a
political perspective in America and
there were almost no pundits including
myself I mean you can go back to the day
lockdown started I was I was I guess
confused as everybody was we were all
smacked with something we had never seen
before hopefully some of us saw it as a
learning lesson years later but 15 days
to slow the spread or whatever it was I
was okay with that on day 15 that's when
I woke up but the point is DeSantis
isn't arguing oh I was perfect from day
one and fought you every which way he's
saying oh I fought you at the beginning
you pushed it on us which is true and we
got rid of it earlier this is all true
so my point my connection from from this
to what we talked about earlier it's not
just about the lying
that so many politicians of the media
are doing it's lying it's the attempt I
suppose to lie your way out of the
results of your own political decisions
right so when Eric Adams is upset that
New York City is a sanctuary City and
then oh my god look what's happening in
our Sanctuary City it's like well you
are lying about what a sanctuary city is
you knew this was going to happen and
Trump now is trying to lie his way out
of his own coveted restrictions so
DeSantis did react to Trump's flurry of
false claims about covet and he needs to
do more of this
he's making claims that Florida had the
third highest death rate in America he
says you shut down yeah that's total
nonsense he said tight as a drone yeah
so vax lines now on April 1st of 2020
just to be clear you did allow the local
authorities to determine who goes on a
beach and who doesn't and I think the
rule you made that day was the limited
to 10 people or less uh do you disagree
with any of that right and it was it
so right so that was a local decision uh
but you know those first few weeks uh we
followed some of the federal guidelines
I've always uh said that uh but then I
was looking at the data myself uh and I
made the decision that we were going to
chart a separate course and so we did
that and clearly Florida boomed as a
result but I would note this because
this is important you know Donald
Trump's re-election campaign in October
of 2020 was running ads bragging with
fauci saying Trump did everything I told
him to do they were putting that out
they were bragging about it and then on
January 19 2021 Donald Trump's last day
as president he gave fauci a
presidential Commendation so those were
wrong to do that uh and clearly I think
the important thing is this looking
forward we need accountability for what
went wrong because those people in
positions of authority at the CDC fauci
though they lied about lockdown school
closures Mass mandates they were wrong
it did a lot of damn damage around this
country and I know that because the
people that were harmed a lot of them
came to Florida and would tell us about
it so we need a reckoning so that this
never happens to our country again and
we instituted permanent Protections in
Florida against Mass mandates against
all this stuff so my question to you is
this
regardless of whether you're supporting
DeSantis whether you're supporting Trump
or anyone else is anything did anything
that he just said right there was it a
lie did he just lie right there nothing
he said there was a lie they adjusted
accordingly Trump was running ads for
re-election with fauci we played one of
them yesterday and we've played it
before and Trump did give fauci and
Berks and a bunch of other people an
award on the way out on his last day in
office it's just true so Trump's
screaming about all this covid stuff uh
but here's a compilation of trump on
covid we closed the country down and we
did just the right thing we closed it
down and a group of very smart people
walk in and say sir we have to close it
and we did the right thing could have
kept it open and I could have done what
some countries are doing bars
restaurants food courts gyms and other
indoor and outdoor venues where groups
of people congregate should be closed
we've done pretty much what he and
others Dr Burks and others who are
terrific recommended when I've made
recommendations he's taken them he's
very important to me and I would I will
be listening to him the president has
listened to what I have said and with
the other people on the task force have
said I thought of keeping it open
because nobody's ever heard of closing
down a country closing down a country to
let alone the United States of America
my Administration is recommending that
all Americans including the young and
healthy work to engage
in schooling from home when possible
avoid gathering in groups of more than
10 people avoid discretionary travel and
avoid eating and drinking at bars
restaurants and public food courts when
He suggests why don't we do this and I
say no that's really not a good idea if
I'm a scientific standpoint he has never
overruled me do you anticipate at all
relaxing those restrictions by region
during these editions I think so I don't
think so and I asked that the same I
said how about Nebraska how about Idaho
how about Iowa I was getting pretty
strong look by these two people they
said we don't like that idea the first
and only time that Dr Burks and I went
in and formally made a recommendation to
the president
to actually have a quote shut down in
the sense of not really shut down but to
really have strong mitigation the
president listened to the recommendation
and went to the mitigation all right I
get it guys hindsight is 20 20. but that
that moment there at the outdoor press
conference at the White House when when
the guy asked him about opening up and
he's like well I looked at these two
people Idaho Nebraska places where
there's a lot of land and a sparse
population everything else and they just
they gave me a strong look so the guy
who said I will drain the swamp who's
still saying he will drain the swamp he
was completely owned by the swamp that
is just true I'm sorry if it pisses you
off it's just true it absolutely is and
again as Brock just pointed out we've
mentioned many times here
everything that Trump says in those
things has he ever said I'm sorry about
any of it or I did get mixed up or I
shouldn't have listened to them or
anything else he really hasn't has there
been a Maya culpa or a moment of
Contrition DeSantis on the other hand is
like yeah we we all made a mistake uh we
all shouldn't have listened to these
guys and blah blah blah Trump seems to
absolutely refuse to do any of that and
then lie about the guy who is leading us
all out of it why am I in Florida right
now why are these guys all in Florida
why did I move two companies here why
did literally almost a million people
move from Florida from California and
New York to Florida in the last three
years why have we seen this massive
population shift leaving blue States
going to Red States it's in large part
because of DeSantis right so let's we
cannot allow them whether it's the left
who lies about everything or in this
case Trump we can't let them rewrite
history because we will not know
anything that is true if we just keep
letting this go on and on here's just
one more from the DeSantis War Room uh
because it's it's worth repeating uh
here's the letter Trump's White House
coronavirus task force sent to Florida
on January 10 2021 just a few days
before Trump left office his task force
was still urging Ron DeSantis to lock
down Florida with strict social
distancing and force everyone to wear
masks you can find the entire thing on
Twitter I'm obviously not going to read
that entire thing to you but you guys
get the point you get the point Trump is
lying about this stuff and was pushing
far to do lockdowns even as DeSantis was
leading I would say the country and the
world out of it right now the other way
that he's lying is he keeps pretending
that he had nothing to do with any of
this it's not just lying about DeSantis
for leading us out of it it's pretending
that he had nothing to do with it now we
just showed you that video As for the
lockdowns I listened to them
here's Trump I think this is two days
ago about covid tyrants
these are bad people these are sick
people we're dealing with but to every
covet Tyrant who wants to take away our
freedom hear these words we will not
comply so don't even think about it
where were you last time man where were
you well interestingly more and more
people are starting to catch on to this
uh Georgia Governor Brian Kemp who was
fighting to open up his State As Trump
was using the power of the federal
government to lock them down he
retweeted that video and he added
comment the fact is former president
Trump led the opposition to my decision
to reopen Georgia the first state in the
country to do so while he listened to
fauci and parroted media talking points
I listened to hard-working Georgians he
may not remember but I sure as hell do
again guys
regardless of who you're supporting or
anything else whether you're pissed at
me for doing this segment just what is
true what do we know to be true what is
there evidence of Truth evidence that
actually occurred
and what and who is lying and what are
they lying about like that's really the
question for today's show uh anyway
interestingly here is now we'll shift a
little bit here because in contrast
here's an anti-lockdown governor who
endorsed Trump and was one of the
leaders on the covid thing but she's not
endorsing DeSantis she endorsed Trump
last time and she's endorsing Trump this
time I'm talking about South Dakota
Governor Christie gnome who I've had on
the show before over the weekend she
endorsed Trump for president
it is my honor to present to you the man
in the arena he is a man of significance
he is the leader the fighter that our
country needs he has my full and
complete endorsement for president of
the United States of America
I will do everything I can to help him
win and save this country ladies and
gentlemen the 45th and the 47th
president of the United States Donald J
Trump okay I want to be clear before I
criticize just a bit here Christy gnome
I think is an excellent governor for the
most part I think she was really
fantastic on covid she was like DeSantis
I would say South Dakota and Florida
were really leading the country out of
covet there were places in South Dakota
that never got locked down at all so I
think she's been great on that stuff and
again I've had her on the show be happy
to interview her again one of the things
that I think she has struggled with uh
is some of the woke stuff that DeSantis
has really crushed it on uh two years
ago the NCAA threatened to pull out of
South Dakota unless she was inclusive of
trans athletes now she had been very
outspoken about separating girls and
boys and etc etc and not letting that
happen which is obviously the right
thing the South Dakota legislature said
no we are not going to play by their
rules she said yes and actually vetoed
the bill that was going to ban trans
athletes from competing it gets into a
little bit of the weeds of South Dakota
politics but you might remember when she
was on Tucker Carlson trying to defend
her view
here you you have this bill which I
think all polling shows is popular in
your state I think would be popular
nationally you said you were excited to
sign it big business intercedes NCAA
Chamber of Commerce and Amazon and tell
you not to sign it and you change your
mind if you I think a lot of our viewers
are wondering you're thinking on this
and how exactly this happened
well that's not true Tucker and thank
you for inviting me to be on the show
tonight I could sign the bill the way
that it is today and then also but it
wouldn't solve the problem and and
that's the real issue as I looked at the
bill and examined it and have been
discussing with legal Scholars for many
months on how to protect women's sports
this bill would only allow the NCAA to
bully South Dakota and it would actually
prevent women from being able to prove
to participate in Collegiate Sports so
what I've done is I've asked the
legislature through a style and reform
I'm sorry but just for our viewers I'm
sorry
can you just back up for one sec for our
viewers who haven't followed this as
closely how how would this bill prevent
women from playing in South Dakota if
you would
because what it would do is it would put
a law in the books that would allow the
NCAA to take punitive action against our
state and you don't think you can win
that fight they said if you sign this we
won't allow girls in South Dakota to
play and you don't think you can win in
court even though the public
overwhelmingly supports you nationally
and so you're caving to the NCAA I think
that's what you're saying for going
after the NCAA and make sure that we're
keeping only girls playing in girls
Sports I've been doing this for years
and I'm going to solve the problem not
just pick a fight to pick a fight
well but the legislature you're saying
was just picking a fight to pick a fight
I thought that they were trying to
codify what the majority of your
citizens want which is girls sports for
girls and boys sports for boys here the
NCAA comes in and says if you do that
you're going to lose a court battle and
so you said well the bill can't go
forward you have a democratic process
that arose from your own citizens they
want this bill and you've stopped it so
I I'm not really sure how this is
defending women's sports
I want to give a hell of a lot of credit
to Tucker in that interview I know in an
interview sometimes when a politician is
kind of Gish Galloping you and they're
kind of talking their way into circles
and it can be hard sometimes to
immediately jump in and try to correct
them he did a great job there what you
got to understand is this bill was put
forth the people were for it the
legislature was for it she vetoed it
okay and now she can make say whatever
she wants Regarding why she did it and
that that the NCAA came in and said
you're going to lose the court case but
you still do what's right you do what is
right which is not allow boys to play
in girls Sports and surprise surprise
you know who did that yeah it was
DeSantis right here in Florida when he
fought Disney so she was afraid of
Amazon he fought Disney which I didn't
even know about this Brock just told me
apparently yesterday Disney dropped
their remaining lawsuits against Florida
I'll get a little bit more on that uh
for tomorrow uh so who who was fighting
the right fight on covet you got it who
was fighting the right fight on the woke
stuff you got it uh so let's show you an
image from the DeSantis war room I
thought this was uh quite good related
to I think we showed you this a while
back but related to parental rights
which really is what this is all about
DeSantis will always stand for parents
rights here is what he has done to
protect families and kids SB 254
outlawing permanent mutilation of minors
this is good HB 1069 removing pronoun
politics and expanding parental rights
in education this is good
hb1438 protecting children's innocence
this is good hp1521
ensuring women's safety this is good
hb225 expanding access to Youth Sports
these are all good things these are all
things that the machine and the
corporations and Disney and the
politicians and the media did not want
the scientists to do but he went through
and did them uh just one more on this
from his hand is warm because I thought
this was just a perfect visual
illustration of what's going on here
here's a map of every state that has
passed all of the following ban on State
and local lockdowns ban on State and
local Mass mandates ban on State and
local vaccine mandates ban on gain of
function research yeah that's Florida
that's right and you know what happens
when you start doing the right thing you
start leading people start getting
braver and then the culture actually
starts shifting right when I was talking
about Trump before how he's now adding
to our culture of lies to santus by
doing the right thing is adding to a
course correction I would say related to
culture because look at this this is
from the Tallahassee Democrat FSU right
here in Florida Florida State University
cancels race class and gender course
ahead of fall semester due to low
enrollment yeah people don't want any of
this nonsense anymore and I want to
throw in one more on this I promise you
this is the last one because one of the
other lies that Trump has relentlessly
had against DeSantis is that he is
somehow Soros backed and then I see all
the anonymous Twitter trolls saying that
Trump is Soros back now ironically
DeSantis uh that DeSantis saw us back
now ironically DeSantis is the only one
who has actually fired Soros back the
A's he did it in Tampa and I think there
was one other one that he got rid of but
there is another guy that Donald Trump
never
criticizes who actually was Soros backed
and it's a guy that Trump never
criticizes and a guy that never
criticizes Trump which is very very
bizarre you know who I'm talking about
of course this is Vivek ramaswamy uh
this is a tweet this one's just popping
up lately people are someone just found
this in the last couple days from the
Soros Fellowship fellowships official
Twitter account
Soros fellowships okay we're very
excited to learn that PD Soros fellow
and Roy event Science and CEO Vivek
ramaswamy is on Twitter even better you
can find his latest essay here and Vivek
responded just joined earlier this year
still slowly figuring out how it works
so yes he was a Soros fellow he's gotten
tripped up in a couple interviews lately
where he said that he only did it
because he needed money then in other
ones he said he didn't need the money to
do it
anyway I thought that was just an
interesting uh piece related to truth
and now one more related to truth and
related to Tucker Carlson that'll tie
this whole thing together
what is it we need to do to fix this
ladies and gentlemen it's just fight for
the right things and do it bravely
whether you're Tucker whether you're
DeSantis whether you're the parent at
the school board meeting whether you're
someone fighting covid tyranny any of
the stuff stand up and do it and you
might see a change go in our Direction
This is Tucker this past weekend
the two things you need to do
are organized
and and speak with total honesty Clarity
and aggression
those are the two things you need to do
now neither one of those things is easy
complaining is easy watching television
is easy
eating with people you agree with and
grousing is really easy that's why those
are the first things I do
when I'm mad about something I whine to
my wife about it I lecture my dogs
all of whom all four of whom agree with
me by the way
I have the most right-wing spaniels in
Maine
but
none of those things change
the outcome
you need to act you need to speak and
you need to organize and before you can
do either one of those you need to
recognize the consequences the stakes
it's not just about people doing things
you disagree with it's about
the most fundamental question of all
which is
can you have children
will they live in a world where they can
afford to get married themselves and
have children and will those children
live where you lived will they live
within driving distance of your grave
well the civilization that produced you
continue
these are I hate the word but these are
literally existential questions well the
world that produced you
continue to exist and the answer is no
with bad leadership it won't everything
is at stake and that's not a fundraising
pitch
yeah it ain't easy guys I get it it
ain't easy to say what you think and
there will be repercussions I find it
very bizarre when I'm out and about or I
do events and people say Dave you're so
brave and it's like listen I'm not going
to war right I'm not being shot at I'm
saying what I think and I guess there is
a cost and there's been a lot of upside
for it to me too but if you do not do it
what do you think is going to happen
after what do you think is going to
happen to the world that your kids are
going to live in and everything else so
we can either just as Tucker says we can
just watch TV we can just complain to
our dogs and all of those things or we
can damn well do it and it and it starts
again by telling the truth and and
Tucker talks about that often which is
why I would love uh and I absolutely
will at Tucker's welcome to come back on
the show anytime I'll text him right
after this to ask him when he'll come
back in but what I would love to know
from Tucker is what do you do about the
lies that I just laid out here it's a
little unclear to me you know look and
Tucker sometimes you he does this thing
where he's sort of like commenting on
politics all the time and then and then
he pretends he has nothing to do with
politics which I think is refreshing in
a bizarre way at some level but the
question I think for someone like Tucker
is okay if you if you believe all of
these things and I believe he's being
forthright and genuine I absolutely do
like which way are you going to vote
like do you still not know I've seen
this lately with a couple pundits on the
right it's like they know what's right
but they're afraid to go against That
Base as Charlie Kirk warned me in that
video we did at the end of July you
don't want to say anything about the
bass because the bass will come after
you and Lord knows they say mean things
about me on Twitter it's true but I'm
doing all right we're gonna order lunch
today
we're gonna have lunch everything's
gonna be fine
fight for the right thing guys that's
that's the point if you have not
subscribed please do it rumble.com
reubenreport and if you want to join us
for the post game show right now it's at
reubenreport.locals.com oh and I saw
this one on Twitter it was going viral
and and I got included in it I thought
you might enjoy it this is about the
Elon Musk vs ADL fight that's been
brewing on Twitter uh take a look and
we'll see on the other side ciao
since Elon Musk took over X formerly
known as Twitter we at the ADL have
noticed a surge in anti-semitic posts
especially from an account named lips of
tiktok
but she's Jewish how how can she be
antisemitic name someone else okay since
Elon Musk took over X formerly known as
Twitter we at the ADL have noticed a
surge in anti-semitic posts especially
from an account Named Dave Rubin
Dave he's Jewish too what are you guys
doing okay let's just
change the script put the right name in
there
it's not your fault
from an account named Ben Shapiro come
on guys he's what do you do who are we
canceling we can't do this
[Music]